fakt ist dass die es geht ja um die
verbreitung der virus mutation b 1 punkt
1.7
und man muss sagen dass diese mutation
ist ja schon in deutschland festgestellt
worden
es geht jetzt eigentlich vor allen
dingen darum die ausbreitung so lange
wie möglich mindestens zu verzögern und
reisebeschränkungen ist eine möglichkeit
aber das wichtigste ist eigentlich dass
wir weiterhin sehr diszipliniert sind
dass wir möglichst wenig kontakt haben
möglichst wenig und in der
öffentlichkeit begeben und wirklich auf
alles verzichten was nicht unbedingt
notwendig ist
das mag ich das frage ich mich dabei
nämlich genau herr mag es wenn das virus
diese mutationen doch schon sowieso hier
ist in mehreren bundesländern bringt das
dann überhaupt noch was wenn man diese
reisetätigkeit dann ins ausland
unterbindet weil hier wird sich das doch
sowieso weiter verbreiten diese mutation
egal ob was wollen oder nicht
ja nein sie haben recht es wird sich
verbreiten darum gehen wir alle aus es
geht
es geht ja nur darum die geschwindigkeit
zu verzögern und jede aktivität und
natürlich je mehr je größer die gefahr
schon gegeben wenn menschen aus dem
ausland zu uns kommen das sozusagen noch
mehr oder noch häufiger dir diese videos
mutation hatten bei uns auftreten desto
schneller geht es dann natürlich
wiederum und es ist nicht wirklich ein
wettlauf mit der zeit zwischen impfungen
und virus aus breitungen mit der
mutation gesehen ja gerade den bürgern
zum beispiel dort sind ja die maßnahmen
vor weihnachten gelockert worden die
haben eigentlich ein relativ normales
weihnachtsfest feiern dürfen und haben
jetzt ein exponentielles wachstum
wirklich größte herausforderungen
sondern auch für das gesundheitssystem
und es geht ja auch darüber ein bisschen
wie wir zum beispiel im sommer gerne
verbringen wollen und ich glaube uns
muss klar sein die disziplinierte und je
weniger wir jetzt tun desto besser
könnte unser sommer oder zumindest
spätsommer werden und wenn wir uns ein
letztes jahr an die erste welle
da waren die maßnahme sehr sehr effektiv
und das hat ja dazu geführt dass wir im
sommer auf so eine gewisse lockerung
dann vertreten konnten und ja auch alle
sehr genossen haben sie sprechen den
sommer an und die zahlen die dann
erwartet werden dass kriegen ja viele
nicht zusammen einerseits geht im moment
endlich die kurve so ein bisschen runter
man hat das gefühl jetzt ist vielleicht
der berg vorübergehend überschritten und
gleichzeitig gibt es diesen harten
warnungen zum beispiel von karl
lauterbach dem spd-gesundheitsexperten
aber auch von virologen christian
drosten die beide sagen hunderttausend
im sommer das ist zumindest ein szenario
das wäre möglich wenn sich diese
mutation so dramatisch eben auch bei uns
ausbreitet teilen sie das also auch der
um damit anzufangen ja die zahlen sinken
wir haben zum beispiel heute 4571
intensivpatienten werden weniger
neuinfektionen das heißt ja vor allen
dingen dass die maßnahmen des lok dann
wirklich wirkung zeigen das ist sehr gut
und das heißt auch dass wir als
bürgerinnen bürger in der großen
mehrheit uns wirklich sehr gut gehalten
haben habe ich ja jetzt auch schon mal
gesagt auch gerade über weihnachten und
silvester das ist gut und richtig oder
aber auch wichtig dass weiter durch zeit
und je konsequenter wir das machen die
diskriminierte wir auch in den nächsten
wochen sind desto weniger wahrscheinlich
ist es dass die mutation sich schnell
ausbreitet schnell wieder zu hohen
infektionszahlen führt und zu große
herausforderung und dann entsprechend
türlich wieder auch zu maßnahmen uns
zwingen die dann wieder eben lockten
bedeuten können und die beiden eben
genannten kollegen haben eben auch die
ausdrucke in spanien polen gesagt irland
vor augen wo die kurven exponentiell wir
nach oben sind innerhalb kürzester zeit
also das ist schon eine reale gefahr
aber wir haben es eben auch einen
gewissen teil zumindest selber da
allerhand was würde denn das für sie was
würde denn das für sie für die
intensivstation für unser
gesundheitssystem ganz konkret bedeuten
wenn diese zahlen die
ihrer meinung nach eine reale gefahr
auch darstellen wenn diese zahlen
tatsächlich eintreten würden 100.000 ja
gut das ist natürlich jetzt eine zahl
die im raum steht
100.000 patienten hat bedeutet nach 10
bis 14 tagen haben wir etwa 200
intensivstationen also das wäre dann
eben entsprechend 2000 patienten aber
man muss ja sagen dass unsere politisch
verantwortlichen also sprich die
bundesregierung die bundeskanzlerin und
auf die minderheit ministerpräsident ja
immer sehr genau zugehört haben was wir
gesagt haben sehr genau die zahl
analysiert haben und ja wir hatten in
deutschland immer früh genug die
maßnahmen auch wenn sie uns noch so
schwer fielen und schmerzt natürlich
dass er genau diese exponentiellen
wachstums ereignisse gebremst haben sie
effektiv gebremst haben und jetzt sogar
einen rückgang haben und ich glaube
tatsächlich dass diese die gute
zusammenarbeit zwischen einen
verantwortlichen auf der einen seite die
mediziner die politische anspannung und
auch die natürlich für die wirtschaft
verantwortlich sind und so weiter hat ja
dazu geführt dass wir bisher eben diese
diese spitzenduo zusage an infektionen
wie wir sie in aller länder ja auch
schon im sommer gesehen haben mit 50
60.000 neuinfektionen tagen das hatten
wir ja gottseidank bisher in deutschland
noch nicht wir sind bild und wie ihr
liefert dir deine news auf youtube zum
nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren